Dilbert has been fired.
The newspaper comic has been around
for more than three decades.
It spawned multiple bestselling books.
It appeared in thousands of newspapers
at its height
with its take on the frustrations
of cubicle work life.
But today,
the syndicate that distributed
Dilbert cut all ties
with its author, Scott
Adams, for blatantly racist remarks.
Adams, on his YouTube
show, referenced a poll by Rasmussen
that's a pro-Trump media company
whose polls do not meet CNN standards.
The poll
suggested
that 53% of black Americans indicated
they agree with the statement It's okay
to be white,
leaving the other 47%
to say they disagree or they aren't sure.
We should note here
the significance of that statement.
It's okay to be white.
The Anti-Defamation
League says that
phrase has a long history
in the white supremacist movement.
So why Rasmussen was polling on it
is anyone's guess.
But here is what some of what Adam said.
So if,
you know, nearly half of all blacks
are not okay with white people,
according to this poll.
Not according to me.
According to this poll.
That's a hate group.
The best advice I would give to white
people is to get the hell away
from black people.
A fairly racist statement,
as blatant as it gets.
CNN's Oliver Darcy watching all of this.
You know,
Oliver Adams, who
we should note,
came on the lead in the early Trump era
a few times
he's been trending more
and more hard-right for years
now into some really bigoted terrain.
But I guess this
apparently crossed the line
into self-immolation
That's certainly correct, Jake.
I mean, if you watch this live stream,
I mean, you just played
some of the comments.
There are frankly very shocking comments.
It seems to be
that he is
promoting effectively
promoting segregation, saying
that white people should not be helping
black people.
They should be staying away from them.
And really
really defending these comments
in later broadcasts that I've watched.
Now, he's
saying he was being hyperbolic
and wanting to start
a conversation about race but obviously
making comments like that's
no way to start this conversation.
He's also positioning himself
as really a free speech martyr here.
But, you know, consequence
he says do follow free speech.
He has the right, of course, to say
whatever he wants.
These newspapers
and other businesses
have a have a right to sever ties
with them. Yeah.
He wants to make this cancel culture.
But this is
this is consequence culture, really.
Now, newspapers
across the country were pulling Dilbert
even before
the syndicate, the distribution company
cut ties with Adams today.
This is going to be potentially
a huge financial blow.
I can imagine that his finances
aren't going to look so great after this,
at least as incomes stream, because,
like you said,
all the newspapers
have really effectively
canceled the Dilbert comic strip.
And it's extended beyond that
at this point.
His publisher,
the publisher of a forthcoming book
that he was set to release in September.
They've now said they're no longer
going to publish that book.
He had tweeted earlier today
that his book agent had canceled on him.
So he's going to have some
professional repercussions
for sure
as a result of these
shocking and racist comments.
Now, whether he's able to leverage
the attention he's receiving
to start something separate,
that remains to be seen.
But in terms
of his previous business model,
that's all but been obliterated, Jake.
Yeah, I mean, he's also in
addition to white
segregation.
He's also
clearly preaching white supremacy.
But now Elon Musk is weighing in on Scott
Adams side of this.
That's
you know,
if the story couldn't get any crazier,
it just did.
I guess it's not too crazy
that Elon Musk would say something
you know, that would draw controversy.
But he was effectively defending
or rushing to Scott's defense
after these shocking comments.
He said
that the media is racist in one tweet.
And then he went on to elaborate
on that tweet,
not not really doing himself any favors.
Now he's saying that
he doesn't always agree
with what Adams does
but that he finds a Dilbert cartoon
funny. Jake.
Yeah.
Nobody's talking about
the Dilbert cartoon.
We're talking about what
Scott said on the YouTube.
Oliver Darcy, thanks so much.